- Voilà nos deux petits lapins.
Je les ai mis dans une enveloppe
parce qu'ils vont chercher des
enveloppes avec des indices.
- Dans sa maison d'Acton Vale,
l'auteur et illustrateur
Philippe Béha met la dernière
touche à son livre pour enfants,
"La course au trésor".
Le Mouvement Québec français
en offrira gratuitement
12 000 exemplaires à des
familles de nouveaux arrivants,
grâce au programme La lecture
en cadeau de la Fondation pour
l'alphabétisation de Montréal.
PHILIPPE BÉHA,
auteur et illustrateur
- Si je fais des enfants, ça va
être trop foncé, ça va être trop
clair, il va s'appeler Mohamed,
il va s'appeler comme ça,
ça marche pas, quelqu'un
va monter aux barricades.
Alors, j'ai dit : non, pas ça.
Des petits animaux. Deux petits
lapins, alors c'est un frère
et uneet uneet uneet une soeur .
- "La course aux trésors"
entraîne les jeunes lecteurs
dans une aventure qui se déroul.
Les deux lapins recueillent
des indices et découvrent
ainsi le Québec. Philippe Beha e
un québécois d'adoption.
Né à Casablanca, au Maroc,
et diplômé de l'École des beaux-
e Strasbourg, en France,
il est arrivé au Québec en 1976.
- Dès que j'ai mis les pieds
à Mirabel, j'étais chez moi.
Et j'ai toujours été chez  été .
Et j'ai toujours cet amour
du Québec, cet amour
des gens, de Montréal.
Montré toujours
ma ville même si maintenant,
j'habite à la campagne.
- Au cours de sa prolifique
carrière, il a illustré plus
de 200 livres pour enfants.
- Les enfants, je les trouvais
extraordinaires; ils sont
brillants, brillants.
C'est après que ça se gâte.
Mais les enfants sont brillants
et... je disais : moi, je
dessiner pour les enfants.
- Même s'il a vu les choses
changer au cours des
45 dernières années, il reste
persuadé de l'importance
pour les tout-petits de
ces moments de lecture.
- C'est sûr qu'ils sont rivés
devant les tablettes, devant
la télé, devant les trucs
et que les guerres, les machins
les affaires, on leur mouline ça
à longueur de
Moi, c'est pas ça que je...
c'est pas la guerre... en Irak
que je
C'est une aventure dans
le boisé avec un petit renard,
et puis c'est leur donner,
pendant un laps de temps très
court, mais leur donner un petit
"break", un petit... moment
qui est à eux dans une lecture
et qu'ils s'évadent là-dedans.
- En partageant l'amourdes mode,
il espère que les petits
lecteurs apprendront
à aimer la langue française
et qu'ils se sentiront
chez eux au Québec.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, A